Hello. good morning.
Well, at least
good morning here
in California.
my name is Jens Asman,
and I'm the CEO
of France Inc.
And our core product that most
of you know about
is is a knowledge
graph tool called
AllegoGraph.
and today, I'm going to talk
about the last
fetched stitches
of dark data. So
for a long time,
well, most of the people in
the audience know
what dark data is.
It's a for a long time,
it was just all
the unstructured text,
but there's actually
even a bigger
pool of dark data
in the enterprise,
and that is
spoken conversations
between customers and company
representatives.
And so today,
I'm going to talk
about how you
can combine speech technology
with knowledge
graphs and about
some of the things
that we learned
in the last four years that
we've been deep into,
speech technology,
NLP, and knowledge graphs.
So, personally,
I worked in the early
late nineties,
in the early two thousands in
the at the the Dutch,
telecom lab,
and we were doing or we were
working on early versions of
Siri and early
versions of iPads,
and I was writing
articles about how,
for example, on an iPad,
you could use speech input to
write your emails and then use
your pen to correct
the mistakes
that you made. and
we were looking
at systems like Siri where we
had a combination of human
assistance and,
and and and speech and and
assistance done by
speech technology.
And it was wonderful,
wonderful world at work,
but I was kind of
always a little
bit hesitant,
and I never could
believe that this
could come to a real,
real systems. Yeah.
So and even in two
thousand fourteen,
that there were articles like
this where people
would say, well,
it's peace recognition,
the unreachable frontier.
And here's an article by James
Kendrick that says voice input
has been a pipe
dream since Star
Trek with crew members talking
into the air and the computers
understanding every
spoken word word.
And he claims
speech technology
can only do ninety
five percent,
which I think he
still was high.
But be that as it may,
my company my my
customers are really,
really happy with
ninety five percent.
Yeah? Because, I mean,
until recently,
they had all that dark data,
all these spoken
conversations,
and they couldn't do
anything with it.
But ninety five
percent is ninety
five percent more
than they ever
could do before, even
infinitely more.
So what I'm gonna talk about
today is what text
analytics, NLP,
knowledge graphs,
and speech technology
can do for
your enterprise or
your enterprise
customer. Right?
And so, of course,
a lot of you guys will be in,
the area of NLP and
text analytics,
and it's a booming
market. Yeah.
So they expect in two thousand
twenty four, text analytics is
already close to a nine
billion dollar,
industry, but
speech is growing
even faster.
Yeah. I mean,
analytics insights
estimates that in two thousand
twenty five, the recognition
the voice recognition market
will be close to thirty one
billion dollars. Yeah.
And speech technology
is becoming
part of everyday life.
I I never would have imagined
that we've got to that point,
but we have now gotten
to that point.
I I'm a big, big fan of,
of Google Voice technology and
their Google Assistant.
I never ever type
an a text message.
I only always will say
my text messages.
I think it's Google
is better than Siri,
but people might
disagree, obviously.
And then, of course,
a lot of you guys will already
have an Alexa in your home,
or you will use
Cortana or Windows,
or you will use something
that IBM made,
but it's become part
of everyday life.
Yeah? And it's not only that
these big companies
create those
technologies, but they also
provide APIs to it. Yeah.
So here's a two
thousand eighteen
comparison where they look at
what Amazon, Google, IBM,
and all the others are doing.
And, I'll leave it
in my presentation.
But what you actually can see
is that even now,
the speech to text is good.
It's never get to the point
where speech to
text is excellent.
So we have for Amazon,
speech to text is good.
For Google, speech to text is
is intermediate.
for IBM Watson, it's good.
So it's getting there,
yeah, these APIs.
and one of the big problems,
and I'm gonna talk
about it today,
is that you really need to be
able to customize,
for your if you wanna
create a service
based on speech technology,
you'll find that there's a lot
of domain words
that these speech
recognizers don't do yet.
I mean, they're getting better
at day over day,
but you need to be able to
customize them.
And that is where right now
the the the biggest problem is
with using these
technologies,
but I'll talk about
it today. Yeah.
And so say you're working for
a big enterprise or a big
enterprise is your
customer. Yeah.
What can you do with spoken,
conversations? Well,
if you look at what people now
do with NLP, it's
mostly focused
on regular text
and documents.
But, believe me,
practices for
text analytics on
documents cannot directly be
applied to spoken
conversations.
We find that normal human
conversations are
so informal,
yeah, that it just
it just won't work.
Yeah. So we had to work for
the last four years to,
to really see what
NLP techniques
we efficiently and effectively
could use for,
spoken combinations.
And so today, I
will discuss a use
case that we did or that we do
with an intelligent
call center.
The call center that
we work with is,
a company in Atlanta called n
three n three results.
they have about
fifteen hundred,
call center operators.
We call them BDRs.
Nearly all of
these people have
a college degree.
So it's an intelligent call
center and a high
end call center
in the sense that
they don't do
just simple scripts,
you know,
the people that call
you every day,
and in most cases,
just following
a a dumb script.
Now these people,
before they make
a phone call,
they first will
investigate the person,
the company,
and then only
then will they do
a a call.
So it's it's for the it's it's
more expensive,
but it's, yeah,
it's it's high end.
And in order to be
get better at this,
they have been
developing a lot of AI,
and we're happy that we could
help with that.
And so they got to the point
that then Accenture
took them over,
two months ago. Alright.
So this is the the call
center company,
that, we work for.
And so we have
a knowledge graph
for this call center company
that is mostly based on just,
structured data. Yeah.
So you have you wanna
build a knowledge
graph for your call center,
whether it's CRM
sales calls or
technical support.
I mean, what are
the things that
you wanna record and what you
can learn just by looking at
the structured
data in your CRM
databases and and,
all the other
systems that keep
track of what's
going on in your
call center. Well,
you wanna know what companies
and individuals did I talk to
before and who's
the best person
to talk to, and
what did I learn
about that company
or the person
in my call.
That's right. And
then your hope
that your people will
make good notes.
and is the person
that I talked
to still working
for that company?
Maybe you have to
go to LinkedIn.
Which of my salespeople made
the most sales and why?
What, or what sales agent is
more effective for
what technology
or what kind of
service, etcetera,
etcetera. So you can imagine
there's a lot of
things that you can,
put in your knowledge graph to
make your sales
processes better.
And so here is a a picture of
a little part of
the knowledge graph.
we call it
the corporate memory
knowledge graph, yeah,
that can answer a lot
of the questions
that I just, showed
you in that slide.
And this is
a picture of Graph,
which is our,
visualization tool
on top of AllegoGraph.
And here you see that m three
might have a client,
like Rocket Cloud Services or
DigitalOcean Cloud Services.
And then when you
have a client,
you do multiple campaigns for
the same client or to focus on
one particular,
element that you wanna sell in
this particular campaign.
And then you will
have the sales
agents here that work
for a campaign,
but, obviously,
they work for
multiple campaigns,
and they have a start time and
an end time. So we we kind of
know when people
started working
for the campaign and when they
stopped working.
And then on the other end,
you have the customers
that you
try to call.
You have, just for fun,
CVS Oakland or Acme Bread.
And then you have
contact people
that initially worked for this
company here and now work for
this company here.
we know a little bit
about the company
and what they sell and what
technology they
already have. Yeah.
And then there are the events
between the call center agents
and the customers.
Yeah. And these are
the core events,
the emails that get sent in
the forced calls. Right?
So you can imagine
this is a kind
of an impressionistic
view of,
our our knowledge graph.
But what we found
out that, okay,
there's already billions of
triples just in
the structured data,
but the real interesting data
is in the voice calls, yeah,
or in the emails between,
call center agents and contact
persons that work
for companies.
Yeah. So this is
where all the magic
happens. So what
do you have to
do to get the interesting data
out of these voice calls?
Well, you need to do
speech technology.
Yeah.
And then once you do that,
what you really
want is to help
the call center
agents in real time.
Yeah. So there's this dream of
real time decision
support. Yeah.
For example,
where is a particular agent in
the sales cycle? Yeah.
Did she move
the process forward?
and and so one of the things
that you'll see several times
is the word bent,
which stands for
budget, authority,
need, and time line. Yeah.
So what you really
want is that
your sales agent
make sure that
before you hand
off a particular
customer that you talk to to
your big client
that will finalize
the sale, for example,
that you really know
that the person
you talk to has
a budget, yeah,
can make a decision,
actually said that
he needs something,
and knows when he needs it.
Right? Okay. So
that is just one
thing that that you can help
sales agents like, hey.
You didn't talk about
the budget there.
Please ask about that.
Then and these are all common
sense things, but
should I correct
for open and
closed questions?
we find that
certain call center
agents talk way
more about product
categories,
whereas others talk
more about sellable products.
So we find that usually it's
better to talk about products
that you can
actually buy. Yeah?
Or how can you
help call center
agents when your
customer talks
about a competitive product?
What you really want is when
this competitive product is
mentioned that you
provide a battle
card in real time.
Battle card is
a card that gives
you the main
arguments against,
your, well,
competitive product.
Or it's also very
important that
if you talk to a customer,
that you know in what
industry it is,
yeah, and what job title and
what his main use case is.
Again, if you
don't know that,
then your sales call
is kinda useless.
So you need to know
all these things.
So we help with that too.
And sometimes you
even wanna do
real time routing.
If you see that the customer
wants to know about
video conferencing,
well, maybe Joe
knows more about
it and just switch
while you're
in the call. Alright.
So these are just
part of the dream
of real time
decision support.
But then if you analyze
the voice calls,
you also can do
regular analytics
that you never
could do before.
Yeah. So for example,
what are the features and
functions that the customer
talks about the most? Yeah?
Or do we see that
there's momentum
for a particular
product that,
whether it's your own product
that you're trying to sell or
a competitor product?
Yeah? And if
the customer talks
about a particular
type of product,
what is the sentiment?
Or why is agent x so good at
selling product
y and way better
than any other of the agents?
and, again, there's
a lot of analytics,
and this is just
a few of the tens
and tens of kind of analytics
that we do on top
of the calls.
Alright. So now so
we have the speech
technology, and
I'll give a demo
in a few minutes.
But all of this
is based on our
architecture for how we deal
with speech and text in our,
Allego graph knowledge
graph platform.
So we can deal with only with
with any kind of input. Yeah.
So, obviously,
we can deal with
regular text that you find in
a in an email,
chat, etcetera.
we do a lot of work
with documents
where we use and
we can take any
kind of documents and then use
a tool called Apache Tika to
turn it into XML and turn it
into smaller pieces,
or we use voice to text,
and we ingest it
in AllegroGraph.
And so now we
have fragments of
text in our database,
but they're just unenriched,
just dumb pieces of text.
If you wanna
analyze that text,
you obviously
need a taxonomy.
So say you're trying to sell,
a sustain a a product around
sustainability, well,
then you better
have a taxonomy,
yeah, that knows
all the important
words related to
sustainability.
Or if you're selling
a particular
product for, one
of your clients,
well, you better have every
product that
the sales agent or
the customer talk
about and have
it in your taxonomy
with the pref
labels and the alt
labels and the whole,
hierarchy of of
important concepts
in in your data.
Yeah. So we work
with tools like
Smart Logic or Pool Party to
create these taxonomies.
We export the taxonomies in
AllegroGraph, and now
we can go to work.
Right? So,
we can take the taxonomy and
text fragments,
give it to our
entity extractor,
and put the entities back into
the knowledge graph.
In that way, enrich the text.
Now we have our own internal
entity extractor
in AllegoGraph
because we deal with very
complicated product names,
and there's not
a single entity
extract on the on the market
that is really
good at it unless
you provide every
alt label that
you can imagine
for a particular
product. but we found
that for product,
it's just better to just have
your own heuristic,
entity extractor so that you
don't have to
provide all these
alt labels. Anyway,
that is so we can use external
entity extractors
that we have around.
Then, obviously,
you wanna have,
the sentiment in the text.
So we have a sentiment
analyzer,
and we add sentiment
back to the text.
sometimes you wanna know what
kind of conversation
you're in.
For example, you
have a conversation
and you wanna know,
is this a direct sales,
or is this a request
for technical help,
or does the customer
wanna replace
all their technology that you
already have or just
wanna optimize it,
etcetera, etcetera.
So we do a lot
of work where we
label conversations
partly automatic,
partly by using,
humans in the loop.
Yeah.
And once we have the labels
added to conversations,
we give that to our
own text classifier.
we have our own internal one,
but you can use external ones
if you want to. Yeah.
And we even put
the classification
model in the the knowledge
graph itself.
So the the classifier becomes
part of the knowledge graph.
And now when we're in a new
conversation and someone
starts to talk,
within a few sentences,
we already know what kind of,
conversation does this,
and we can start giving real
time help to the the call
center agents.
The name another
important part
is that you really
wanna know,
especially when you build
recommendation engines,
is what are the terms that are
usually used together
with other terms.
So we do a lot of work
on co occurrence,
correlations, odd
ratios between terms,
and we use that
for, our, well,
recommendations and and and
other things. And once you've
done all of that,
then the fun can start and you
can do a semantic
search and and,
semantic exploration.
You can apply your analytics,
and you can do FR queries,
or you can provide real time
decision support.
So this is kind of
a little overview.
This is kind of
an overview of,
our our system. Alright.
So but I promise
to talk a little
bit more about our taxonomy
trained speech recognizer.
so as I said before,
one of the problems
with the commercial
speech recognizers
that you can buy,
yeah, or get
a subscription for
is that they're really good at
regular language
but fail, at,
product names, yeah,
at regular names.
So what you really
want is a speech
recognizer that you can train
from a taxonomy. So
that's what we did.
We took, we we we
created several,
tools where we can
take an an existing
taxonomy with the prev labels
and the alt labels,
use that to train
the speech recognizer.
and then when you get
the transcription
from your speech recognizer,
you'll find that
the quality of
the text output
is way better.
That makes it that the entity
extractor is way better,
and the output of
your entities.
And so the whole quality gets
better by having a taxonomy
trained speech recognizer.
So that is the thing that we
specialize in. So,
here is a little
demo of that.
Let me see if I have a better
version of that.
So for example,
after every after every sales
call that people
do, they are,
required to fill in a summary
of what they talked about with
the customer.
We call that a a note
taking app.
And in that note taking app,
we wanna know, okay,
what products were mentioned,
where the competitors
mentioned,
what's the job title,
did people talk about the band
categories that I
talked about before.
And so,
let's see if I can
find this here.
Yeah. Here.
So here, we have someone,
that uses this
little application.
Let me see how that goes.
So I talked to Bob Johnson.
He's a VP of
engineering for the.
They said he they want to buy
some routers, and,
specifically,
they consider Cisco
RB two hundred
fifteen w and,
Jupyter CTP two
thousand fifty six.
Yeah. And we can't really hear
the audio. Oh, okay.
So, basically yeah.
Okay.
Let me just then do this.
We trained this beforehand.
Let me just explain
what happened.
Yeah? So, basically,
this is a person,
talking to this application to
give a summary of
what was talked
about and the output
of why and
and what you saw
here move around
is the same thing you
see on your phone.
That's why you're
talking through
your phone. You see
that the speech
recognizes making corrections
on the fly to get better
interpretations. But what we
then do is we take
out the entities
that are important to us,
like the products mentioned,
the competitors,
the job title,
and the band title.
So let me go here and go back
to my presentation. Yeah.
But the important
thing is the important
thing is that once we're done
with this conversation,
the entire
conversation will be
instantly in our
knowledge graph.
So what you see
here is for this
particular little session that
you just saw, and
I'm sorry that
the speech quality
wasn't better,
We see that there was this
particular session.
There's a bunch of phrases in
this session. One of them was
so I talked to Bob Johnson,
so VP of engineering.
And this is
the text fragment,
and then here is the result of
entity extraction.
And we found that, okay,
there was a job title in this
particular phrase.
It's VP of engineering,
which is has a broader
contact person.
So these are terms that come
from a taxonomy.
And here we see, that
is another phrase,
and here was about some
of the technologies
. And we'll find that in this
particular phrase,
we then found
the Jupyter routers.
well, anyway, as you can see,
various products.
So within a second
after you're
done talking,
it's already part
of your knowledge graph,
and you can do analytics
on top of that.
Now what did we learn,
during these last four years
that we've been
specializing on
speech technology and NLP with
knowledge graphs?
so the first thing
that I already
talked about is
that most speech
to text systems fail on very
specific domain words. Yeah?
What's product names,
medical terms,
financial terms, etcetera.
And the customization
is in its infancy.
So what you really need is get
really good at
customization in
a very short amount of time.
Because our
customer gets a new
campaign, and they can't wait
weeks to train a new model.
They they want
to start working
the next day.
So we spend a lot of time on
the customization processes.
And for static domains,
we can train language models,
but we also use speech to text
systems that allow
you to train
using phonetics.
That's a very important one.
Then, in the audience,
there are undoubtedly people
that built their
own taxonomies,
but I can tell
you that building
the old labels for terms,
that you normally do
for text is really,
really different than when you
do it for spoken
conversations.
Yeah?
The sales agent will say cat
nine k instead of
Cisco Catalyst
nine thousand l. Right?
So it's a lot of
work for us to
get this done.
And then there's
the issue with numbering.
Just a simple issue
with the word
nine thousand
hundred twenty one
or ninety one
hundred twenty one,
yeah, or nine one two one.
There's so many
ways that people
can say these numbers.
So you need to
deal with that.
Then it's pretty hard that are
it's it's a a problem that
especially with
short words. Yeah.
They overlap too often with
the regular English terms.
So we spend a lot of time on
making sure that
we actually get
the right word when we train
the systems. And then,
there's all these
little tricks
that you learn, like,
don't put the client
name before
every product name.
So in a Cisco catalog,
every word is
prefaced by the word
Cisco. But the problem is,
that if you do that
also in your,
in your when you train your
speech recognizer,
that the thing becomes
way too greedy.
Yeah?
And all the words
become Cisco.
So you don't wanna
do that thing.
So anyway and this is
just a few things.
I mean, there's
there's literally
hundreds of little things that
you learn when
you try to train
these systems in
a very fast way.
And we actually
wrote an application
just to deal with numbers and
product names to to
create a proposal
for phonetics, and,
you can contact
me later on how
we do that.
Then lesson three is,
you need a speech recognition
assist a speech
recognizer that
provides both real time and
batch processing, obviously.
if you wanna do
real time decision
support, you better
do real time
processing. One of the issues
is when you saw my demo,
you saw that
the speech recognizer
was correcting itself
all the time.
Yeah. So one of
the big questions
is how can how
long can you wait
till you trust
the transcription?
And, obviously,
for some things,
you don't need to
do real time,
processing batch processing is
good enough.
but not all speech recognizers
are really good at real time
decision support.
Then another thing is,
we as human beings are really
good at separating
who's who's talking,
who's saying what. Right?
But it's still an active area
of research, yeah,
to do it, for,
say, spoken
conversations where
you don't have
any visual help.
Yeah. And it's very important
because what we find
is, initially,
we were just taking
a transcription
of both the agent
and the customers
at the same time,
but the results weren't
that valuable.
What really makes a difference
is if you can split
what the customer
is saying about a product
or competitor,
etcetera, and what
the agent is saying.
Yeah. And so right now,
we don't trust the speech
recognition systems
too much to,
tell you who's speaking,
but we try to do
it at the level
of the the the telephone
routers.
But the problem
with the telephone
routers is that
it's also fairly
new to all of them,
because they were
always used well,
they were built for regular
human to human
conversations and not to,
help speech
recognition systems.
So, again, this is all fairly
new and exciting research.
then some speech recognizers.
So the other thing is you can
so speech recognizers
make mistakes.
Right?
So you get
a transcription back.
but some speech
recognizers give
you for a phrase or a word
multiple interpretations.
So then in your
entity recognizer
or phrase recognizer,
you can still do a lot of,
post processing. Yeah.
and so, again, if you wanna
choose a speech recognizer,
you better get one
that gives you,
multiple interpretations
of words.
and then how well does your
speech recognizer with
other languages,
and are they all of
the same quality?
Well, some of you
live in the world
of text analytics, and,
you probably know that even if
you just do NLP
on static text,
yeah, there's a difference in
the quality of,
the the the languages
even within
the same product. Yeah.
The product might be really,
really good for, English,
but then way worse
for, say, Korean.
Yeah.
Maybe because for English,
they use WordNet, internally,
but for Korean,
they only use lists
or words. Yeah?
So you get different.
But in speed
recognition system,
it's even more
pronounced. Yeah?
So when you look at the speech
recognition system,
you also wanna
look at how good
are they for multiple dialects
of English or Spanish.
And some of them are starting
to specialize to
kinda recognize
almost all kinds of English,
or all kinds of Spanish,
and some of them only
do one dialect.
So and then on top
of all of this,
if you, like we do,
work on on creating,
speech recognition systems for
multiple language as well.
It's a huge problem that if
the people that work for you
don't speak all
these languages,
so that's
a a little additional
problem that you might
wanna deal with.
Then quality control.
so we learned that,
automated testing
is like, well,
everywhere. It's
very important.
So we have for every campaign
and for every language,
a gold standard conversation,
and then we run it
every x minutes
to see if the right words and
the phrases come back.
And we also found
that you can't
do it without
a human in the loop
because if you train a speech
recognized on your
text taxonomies,
some of the regular English or
any other language
deteriorates,
and only a human
can detect that
can detect that.
So we try to avoid,
an I'm sorry.
Now I'm going too fast. Yeah.
So only a human
can detect that,
so we always have
a human being
that at least
does some quality
control to see where we are.
And, what this person actually
most looks at is
to avoid false
positives. Yeah.
We don't wanna
tell our customer
that in conversations,
a particular,
product was mentioned
too many times.
We rather we rather
not recognize
the term and miss some words
than that we tell the customer
that there are too
many of a particular
word recognized.
And, again, you need automated
testing and a human
little loop
to deal with that. Alright.
So concluding,
if you wanna do
a speech technology
project, we are really
happy to help,
and help you to incorporate,
the output of
speech technology
in your knowledge
graphs because
there's really some amazing
business benefits
in all of that,
and it's really,
really fun to do.
So thank you for
your attention,
and maybe there are
some questions.
Thank you for your talk.
it was great, as
usual, I should say.
We we have one
question here in
the chat,
about how you combine speech
analytics and EU,
GDPR regulations.
how is that working together?
Well, the same kind of applies
in the United States too.
Some states allow
you to record,
conversations
with permission.
Some states allow
you to record
without permission.
but in a country
like Germany,
nothing is allowed. Yeah.
But the laws have not been yet
really defined
for listening in
using speech technology.
Right? So it does
not so you are
allowed to listen
in with a an an
automated system and extract
the most important
words out of a text.
There's no one I
haven't seen yet,
anyone that would,
forbid you to do that.
Although, of course,
the GDPR still
completely applies
because even if
you get elements
out of a a conversation,
that's coupled to
a particular customer,
and that customer, of course,
is under the GDPR.
So if you wanna
forget about it,
then you have to be
able to forget.
But remember,
when I showed you
my picture of,
a knowledge graph,
we do have because
we have this
knowledge graph,
we actually know
every word that
every customer ever
ever uttered.
Right? So we can we actually
have a system where
we can forget.
Yeah. Because we
have completely
documented.
But it's a it's
a very complicated
topic for call center.
Really, really complicated.
another question
from Frederick
Landbisque. Bisque,
did you acquire from that
foundational
taxonomies to jump
start the training,
or and or or have
you incorporated
open vocabularies
in in your system?
Actually, we,
so one of the fears of any
customer is that they have to
do all
the taxonomy development
all the way from the start.
Yeah. And so we
use, at at entry,
use the the, want technology.
There's a company
called want,
w a n d, yeah, that
provides some,
foundation taxonomies.
And so you can
start with those,
and then you can expand.
These wall taxonomies
don't have
many alt labels,
but at least it's
always a great
start of the core
hierarchy that
applies in
the particular domain.